not to be confused with the game catalog
of the premium and extra tier or the
monthly free games in the essential tier
PlayStation Plus collection launched in
2020 exclusively for PlayStation 5
owners and it included a number of
Sony's big first party games as well as
a few third-party goodies at the time it
was a great way for new members of the
PlayStation family to experience some
games they might have missed out on now
with the inclusion of the aforementioned
game catalog and it's starting to make a
little less sense and Sony has confirmed
that it will be discontinued later this
year in a blog post Sony revealed
PlayStation 5 owners will have until
Tuesday May 9th to claim the games in
the collection which will quote enable
you to access those titles even after
that date for as long as you remain a
PlayStation plus member and with 7.1
PlayStation 5S being sold in just the
last three months alone I'd say there's
potentially millions of you out there
that haven't added these games to your
library yet the company went on to say
that it will focus efforts on adding new
games to its PlayStation Plus library of
monthly free games and evolving the game
catalog the premium and extra tiers of
PlayStation Plus currently offer a
substantial collection of first party
and third-party games a lot of which
were also offered in the PlayStation
Plus collection however this comes at an
increased price in comparison to the
basic offers of the service but remember
being an essential member still has its
perks as you can still get the monthly
free games as a part of your
subscription February 2023's games
consist of Destiny 2's expansion Beyond
light Ali Ali World Evil Dead and Mafia
Definitive Edition and fun fact about me
I've only played Mafia 3 so I'm pretty
excited to try out the first one when it
arrives on PlayStation Plus next week on
February 7th in other news CD projekt
Red has rolled out a new patch for The
Witcher 3 wild Hunt which it says will
improve the overall stability and
performance of The Game on current gen
consoles and PC for PC users the patch
will fix an issue where the screen space
reflection setting wasn't working even
when being switched on and a new
performance mode for raytrace Global
illumination has been added as well if
you have the right hardware for this
setting you'll be able to toggle it on
and see your frame rate improved on
PlayStation 5 and Xbox series X an issue
where consoles would create a higher
amount of saves than their set limit has
been addressed and Screen space
reflection qualities have been improved
here too cdpr says that raytrace Global
illumination has been further optimized
thus improving the performance of The
Game's Ray tracing mode a few more
changes can be found across the various
quests and general gameplay fixing
issues and missions such as battle
preparations Kings Gambit Family Matters
and a dangerous game several of these
quests had invisible obstacles events
that weren't being triggered and other
lingering issues that would haul
progress but these have all been fixed
now cdpr added that the patch also
contains other minor fixes that didn't
make a it onto the list which combined
will help improve gameplay across
systems now in the comments I want you
to do one of two things or I guess both
tell me how much you love The Witcher
just because I like to read it and then
tell me if you think PlayStation Plus is
just a little too complicated I think
getting rid of collection is going to
like clear up a little bit of confusion
but I think there's still a lot of
confusion out there especially with all
the different tiers so let me know and
I'll see you tomorrow
thank you